hey guys this is Cameron with motion
science and I've got another quick one
for you today this one has to do with
textures last week I put out a video on
how to use the set mat effect in After
Effects and I had a lot of you email and
comment that you wanted to know how I
created the moving textures inside of
this MTV logo so here you can see the
moving textures inside the logo that I
talked about last week so I just want to
show you very quickly how I created
these moving textures the first thing I
should mention is that you can see over
here in the timeline that these three
layers pre comps of textures are set to
color and multiply in a normal transfer
mode I'm not gonna get into that stuff
this week but let me show you what I how
I created one of these textures which
let's focus on the black and white
texture by going to this pre comp you
can see here there's a whole bunch of
layers 32 layers this comp is set to 24
frames per second and I'll just delete
these layers I'll go up here to my black
and white texture folder and I've just
selected pre-selected these few textures
here and what I'm going to do is just
drop one in here and you can see I've
got a large texture in my 1080p comp so
it's great to have a texture that's
larger than your comp so they have more
room to work with so the first I'm going
to do is I'm just gonna scale it up to
somewhere in here close 250% I'm also
going to make this a very short layer so
we just see it for one frame of the 24
frame sequence and then I just find the
part of the frame that looks interesting
maybe they're duplicate
maybe somewhere in here I'm actually
gonna drop jump back into my first comp
and here's a little trick for y'all know
it if you go up your composition window
here in the left corner click on comp 1
or whatever your comp is named click new
comp viewer kind of pop up a second
viewer here and inside this viewer I can
go back into my texture sorry this
window and I can move my texture around
I can see how it looks over here on the
right side so I'll duplicate again maybe
drag over here bring in another texture
set it to be one frame as well it's
great there duplicate you move it there
duplicate again in here bring in the
next texture and you get the idea here
so I'm going to speed through this so
you can see the whole process
okay and you could see like on this
particular texture it looks like there's
a lot of black going on here but when we
layer other textures on top some of this
area will fill in so it's okay to have
negative space in the textures so I
still have a few sections here of
timeline to fill up so I might just
select a few of these duplicate them
take them to the top of the timeline
maybe one more
yeah so it's just simple black-and-white
textures but put together in a sequence
where each texture is very short it
turns into like a moving texture and if
we look over here all I did then was
just duplicate the same process in
texture 2 and then in texture 3 to give
my color to the logo it's just a bunch
of watercolors in the same simple
fashion so there you go there's how to
create simple moving textures in your
motion graphics hope you guys learned
something new please leave a comment
below like subscribe and until next time
I'm Cameron and this is motion science